What goes up must come down right?
But what if what goes up into our atmosphere
doesn’t come down in the same place?
Hey guys thanks for watching DNews, I’m
Julia
A recent viral documentary called Under the
Dome shined a spotlight on China’s pollution
problem.
According to the film, last year, in beijing,
175 days were considered “polluted” where
people couldn’t even go outside the smog
was so bad.
According to EU air quality standards, less
than 1% of China’s population breathes clean
air daily.
It’s so bad it’s even been compared to
what a nuclear winter might look like.
Smog is made of aerosols, small particles
of matter emitted mostly from the burning
of fossil fuels.
In China most of the smog comes from car exhaust
and coal fired power plants which blasts large
amounts of sulfur dioxide.
This reacts with water vapor and other gases
in the atmosphere to create sulfate aerosols.
Once in the atmosphere these particles can
have a huge impact on the climate.
In strong concentrations they can refract
or scatter sunlight and even change the way
clouds form.
But China’s so far away, what has that got
to do with us in America?
Well we’ve had a nasty winter the past few
years.
There were Snowpocalypses and Snowmaggedons.
Boston was buried in snow for the beginning
of this year.
One study published in the Proceedings of
the National Academy of Sciences suggested
that China’s pollution is to blame.
A team from NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory
and the California Institute of Technology
found that once these Aerosols enter the atmosphere
but they don’t just hover above China.
They’re picked up by wind currents and move
fast.
Particles moving with the atmosphere at 16.4
feet per second will travel thousands of miles
in a week.
China’s pollution can travel across the
Pacific Ocean, along the way it makes clouds
bigger and wetter.
The particles give the water molecules something
to cling to.
This may make more storms and make them bigger
and wetter and in turn changes the polar jet
stream and then everything gets all messed
up and we get worse winters.
Although not surprisingly, the researchers
say they haven’t reached a final conclusion
and SAY IT WITH ME PEOPLE “More research
is needed”!
But smog isn’t the only thing going into
the air.
Two recent studies showed how dust from the
Sahara Desert might feed the Amazon.
In the same way smog is picked up in the atmosphere,
so is dust from the desert.
One study published in Remote Sensing of the
Environment found that wind and weather pick
up 182 million tons of dust a year.
The dust then travels 1,600 miles across and
27.7 million tons of it falls on the Amazon.
But that dust is carrying something important,
phosphorus.
A recent paper published in the journal Geophysical
Research Letters found that an estimated 22,000
tons of it from the Sahara falls on the Amazon
every year.
Phosphorus is a vital nutrient plants need
to grow.
How crazy is that?
Something from the one of the most barren
places on Earth, makes another place the most
fertile.
Like the author of the Sahara study said,
"This is a small world and we're all connected
together."
Switching gears for a second, did you know
we’re all connected by poop?
Yeah not really but poop transplants are a
thing that could potentially save lives.
Our brand spanking new sister channel, Seeker
has a whole amazing video about it, where
DNew’s own Trace went to go see how it’s
done.
Check it out.